NICOLAI MUNK PETERSEN:
Unity is a game engine that
works on multiple platforms.
Unity is a great way to build
both 2D and 3D experiences,
and we have created
a Unity package
for Project Tango and Android.
My name is Nicolai,
and in this video,
I'll show you how
hard-- well, actually,
how easy it is to integrate
motion tracking in Unity.
Project Tango packages
a set of new computer
vision-enabled features
for mobile devices.
It takes the sensor readings
from multiple sensors
and fuses them
together on the fly.
Based on that
description, you might
think that it's going to be
a lot of work to integrate.
If you are new to Unity,
check out the developer videos
and download the Unity
development environment.
It's pretty big, so you
might want to do that now.
To use this new package you need
Unity, the Project Tango SDK,
and a Project Tango
enabled device.
Let's get started.
Hi, [? Jared ?].
Do you mind helping us out?
[? JARED: Hi, ?] Nicolai.
Of course.
Let's do this.
To save some time, let's
start with a project
that I've already
built in Unity.
This project does not
use Project Tango,
and we will add
motion tracking to it.
Currently, I can use
the keyboard and mouse
to move the camera
around, and I want
to change that to
use Project Tango.
To work with Unity
and Project Tango,
you need the most
up-to-date Unity package
from the developer website.
If you don't already have
that, go ahead and get it now.
With Unity set up
and updated, I'm
going to import the
latest Unity package
right into my project now.
Now that the Project Tango
SDK is part of my project,
I need to place the
Tango Manager prefab.
You'll find this prefab,
along with other Project Tango
prefabs, in the
Tango Prefabs folder
at the root of your project.
Let's place it.
In the Tango Manager
prefab, you're
going to choose how to use
Project Tango in your scene.
I want to use motion
tracking, so I
need to check Enable
Motion Tracking.
You can enable
other options here
for using other parts of Project
Tango, such as Enable Depth,
for depth sensing,
and the UX library,
for displaying the
initial connection.
You can check out the
documentation linked at the end
to learn more.
OK, that's it for configuring.
Now, let's replace the
current camera with one
controlled by Project Tango.
We will use the Tango
Delta Camera prefab.
I'll place that
prefab in my scene
at the same position
as the existing camera.
And then I have to disable
the existing camera.
This camera is
called a Delta camera
because it calculates the
change of position and rotation
for the device.
The camera follows the motion
of the device precisely,
but, of course, we don't want
anyone walking through walls.
So, it uses the Unity
character controller
to keep everybody safe.
And as an added
benefit, this makes
it easy to replace cameras in
existing games with the Delta
camera.
Of course, your own
game may not fit
into the default shoebox,
which is why you can customize
the Tango Delta camera.
For example, it is
straightforward to change
the camera view to a top-down,
or third person view.
Select the multi-camera child,
and change the mode here
to third person, or top-down.
But let's stick with
first person for now.
By default, this prefab
shows a motion trail.
I can hide the trail
of where I've been
by disabling this trail child.
Actually, I'm going
to do that right now.
It's a cleaner look.
Finally, let's get this
running on my tablet.
In order to build and run
this project on my tablet,
I have to build it on Android.
So I go to the Build settings.
I'm already set up for Android.
So now I'll build and
run it on my device.
It's all done.
Let's try it out.
Pretty awesome.
NICOLAI MUNK PETERSEN:
Thank you, [? Jared. ?]
As you can see, it's
pretty straightforward
to integrate motion tracking
with your experience
to control the
camera perspective.
In addition to
controlling the camera,
you can use motion tracking to
directly control your avatars.
Watch the user experience
videos to learn
how to take full advantage
of motion tracking,
avoid the pitfalls, and
create stunning motion
enabled experiences.
And don't forget to visit our
Google+ community and join us
on our journey.
We are excited to see what you
will build a Project Tango.
[MUSIC PLAYING]